now to those thanksgiving celebrations
the field this year is
quite different health officials have
been asking people to avoid those big
gatherings and travel
as coveted cases continue to rise many
say they are taking those extra
precautions
joe moeller spoke to some local shoppers
just like the rest of 2020 thanksgiving
this year is going to be a little bit
different here's a look at the
albertsons at maryland parkway and
flamingo shoppers have been coming
in and out all throughout the day
grabbing their last minute items we
spoke to a few who say they are taking
precautions this year
typically people have family over and
people make
big meals this year the cdc recommends
people to stay home and keeps
gathering small shoppers grabbing last
minute items say their gatherings will
be different
some are having less people while others
are having family members wear a mask
my whole entire family is coming over so
we're all going to have our mask on
still
even though we're family yeah
because one of our cousins are sick so
we're just going to protect her we also
stopped by the welcome to las vegas sign
which was a popular spot today visitors
say they still felt safe coming here to
town
many we spoke with say people on the
strip are taking precautions but they
notice the strip does not feel the same
now despite the differences people are
noticing for thanksgiving this year they
say they're still thankful
to enjoy the holiday reporting in las
vegas joe moeller 8 news now